loin de l'europe et dans une certaine
indifférence se joindre à mu militaire
qui décime la population de l'angola ce
pays touché depuis près de 30 ans par la
guerre civile est aujourd'hui dévastée
par la famine premières victimes les
enfants
il souffre de grave malnutrition les
associations sur place lance un
véritable cri d'alarmé
les images que vous allez découvrir
tourné par médecins sans frontières dans
des zones jusqu'alors inaccessibles à
cause de la guerre ces images sont
difficiles parfois insoutenable mais
telle est la réalité de l'angola
aujourd'hui chara kris meeke
ils attendent depuis des heures mais ils
sont remplis d'espoir au bout du chemin
de l'huile et de la farine
chacun d'entre eux n'a connu que la
guerre et la famine
toi
surtout pour ne pas marcher à l'hôpital
de campagne que gère aussi médecins sans
frontières beaucoup d'enfants
réapprennent à boire et à manger tôt
allez après des semaines d'épreuves ils
ont échappé à la mort
reste la malnutrition et la maladie
voyez comme ses enfants et son coiffeur
sa voiture corps sont très plaintif se
plaignent sont extrêmement héritan ils
veulent pas qu'on s'occupe de vous sans
caractéristiques de la maladie puis
cette poule et cahiers il plein d'une
serre c'est tout à fait caractéristique
on voit que ça devenait livres et pierre
langlois cette femme reprend espoir
l'enfant mange maintenant tout seul la
vie a repris le dessus
on est un peu débordé à chaque endroit
où on va on essaie de monter une mission
on essaie de trouver des stratégies pour
répondre
au mieux à la catastrophe car il s'agit
bien d'une catastrophe
cinq cent mille personnes vivent dans
ces conditions en angola alors que le
pays est très riche grâce à son pétrole
et à ses diamants